[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual política os
hago una pregunta quien ha ganado
realmente las últimas elecciones en los
eeuu las elecciones de mitad de mandato
ha sido el partido republicano el
auténtico vencedor o ha sido en cambio
el partido demócrata que podemos esperar
a partir de ahora amigos como sabéis el
pasado martes 7 de noviembre de 2018 se
celebraron las elecciones de mitad de
mandato en ella se eligieron a 435
congresistas a 35 senadores y a 36
gobernadores además de otros muchos
cargos locales como alcaldes jueces y
sheriff vamos que las elecciones de
mitad de mandato no son ninguna broma
hay mucho en juego precisamente por eso
estas elecciones han sido toda una
contienda una batalla encarnizada y es
que veréis en los eeuu las elecciones de
mitad de mandato además de elegir a
congresistas senadores y gobernadores
tienen también mucho de plebiscito sobre
la dirección política del presidente
este combate lo pudimos ver por ejemplo
en la mismísima texas un bastión
republicano desde hace décadas donde a
punto estuvieron de escoger a un senador
demócrata y un demócrata ganando hoy
en la tierra de los cowboys pues amigos
ya no parece tan improbable pues bien
nuestra misión en este vídeo va a ser
echar un vistazo a las claves de las
elecciones a los tantos logrados por el
partido demócrata y a los tantos
conseguidos por el partido republicano y
sobre todo también veremos qué podemos
esperar de aquí a las presidenciales de
atentos victoria demócrata muchos
esperaban una enorme ola azul que es el
color del partido demócrata sin embargo
los resultados han sido mucho más
discretos y los republicanos han logrado
consolidar y ampliar su mayoría en el
poderoso senador norteamericano y
defenderse relativamente bien en la
elección de gobernadores
ahora bien esperad un momento porque
decir eso es dejarnos muchas cosas en el
tintero lo que vimos el pasado martes
fue una reñida lucha que dibujó dos
países muy diferentes por un lado las
grandes zonas urbanas mayoritariamente
demócratas
a las zonas rurales que siguieron
apoyando fue realmente al partido
republicano mira este es el mapa que
dejó la elección a la cámara de
representantes que fue la elección que
se produjo en todo el país
[Música]
pues bien tal y como veis el mapa es
rojo el color del partido republicano
pero amigos no os dejéis engañar por las
apariencias lo cierto es que los
demócratas aquí lograron un resultado
bastante pero que bastante notable
especialmente en lo que a voto popular
se refiere fijaos de los 435 distritos
en los que se divide el país en ni más
ni menos que 317 el partido demócrata
mejoró sus resultados en promedio en
unos 10 puntos
[Música]
y aún más aunque en eeuu los recuentos
son muy pero que muy lentos la
diferencia total que los demócratas
sacaron a los republicanos puede estar
en torno a los siete puntos y miradme
bien eso en términos de voto es una
paliza sí sí ya sé que en eeuu eso no es
importante luego lo veremos pero de
momento tanto para los demócratas el
caso es que todo esto claro se ha
traducido en que este partido el partido
demócrata se haya hecho con la mayoría
de la cámara de representantes-
recuperando entre 30 y 37 escaños si en
el momento de hacer este vídeo varios
días más tarde aún hay muchas carreras
sin terminar pero aquí no termina todo
además los demócratas recuperaron siete
gobiernos estatales su mejor resultado
desde 1982 illinois nevada main nuevo
méjico michigan
kansas y wisconsin en estos tres últimos
estados por cierto donald trump ganó en
las últimas presidenciales
y todo esto además de suponer más poder
es algo crucial de cara a las elecciones
de 2020 los gobernadores tienen
influencia y muchos recursos eso sí por
los pelos perdieron florida respecto al
senado es verdad que los republicanos
han ampliado su ventaja pero en unas
elecciones donde los demócratas
defendían 26 escaños y los republicanos
tan sólo 9 escaños además elegidos hace
6 años antes de que fuera siquiera
imaginable el terremoto político que ha
vivido el país ahora bien amigos estos
son los resultados más visibles pero las
elecciones nos han dejado mucha más
información atentos
[Música]
a pie de urna
lo siento donald trump es un presidente
bastante impopular bastante más que sus
predecesores no lo decimos en visual
político lo dicen las encuestas y ahora
también los votos amigos a falta de
resultados definitivos tal vez lo más
preocupante para el partido republicano
es ver lo que está ocurriendo con la
composición de voto veréis me explico
los demócratas han arrasado entre las
minorías entre los jóvenes y entre las
mujeres ahora incluso ya ni siquiera
pierden entre las mujeres blancas un
segmento de voto en el que los dos
partidos han empatado de hecho los
republicanos sólo han ganado entre los
hombres blancos
tenemos el comienzo de un nuevo partido
demócrata más joven de piel más oscura
más guay con más veteranos de guerra que
puede ganar en michigan en pensilvania
en ohio van jones comentarista político
amigos el votante promedio del partido
republicano es un hombre blanco de
mediana edad que vive en áreas rurales o
pequeños núcleos urbanos y que no tiene
estudios universitarios si entre la
población con estudios superiores
los demócratas han ganado el voto por 20
puntos
es un problema
a pesar del buen momento económico que
vive en los eeuu el perfil político de
donald trump está dejando fuera al
partido republicano de los segmentos de
la población que más crecen y también de
las ciudades y los espacios con mayor
nivel académico que a largo plazo suelen
tener mucha influencia y son sobre los
que pivotan los nuevos modelos
económicos
mis ciudades ni profesionales con
estudios superiores ni mujeres ni
minorías ese es el partido republicano
que está construyendo donald trump esto
es lo que explica que incluso en un
estado tan importante para el partido
republicano como texas
los demócratas estuvieran a punto de
ganar con uno de sus candidatos
revelación beto o'rourke la carrera al
senado
al final el republicano ted cruz mantuvo
el escaño pero la diferencia fue muy
pequeña texas empieza a ser un estado en
juego
claro que amigos este partido también ha
tenido motivos para sacar pecho atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
triunfo republicano
un momento un momento espera no nos
equivoquemos el partido republicano
también tiene motivos para sacar pecho
al fin y al cabo el cambio de color
político la cámara de representantes-
respecto a la casa blanca en las
elecciones de mitad de mandato es algo
habitual
de hecho en escaños que no en votos
los republicanos han perdido menos
asientos que por ejemplo bill clinton en
el 94 o barack obama en 2010 y ambos
presidentes lograron dos años después la
reelección además como hemos visto por
un motivo o por otro el caso es que
también lograron afianzar y ampliar su
mayoría en el senado con lo que la
administración trump se asegura poder
frenar las iniciativas legislativas
demócratas y mantiene la capacidad para
confirmar jueces y miembros de su
administración
además estas elecciones prácticamente
han evitado que un posible proceso de
impeachment que necesita el referendo
del senado pueda tener éxito y tal vez
lo más importante de todo como sabéis en
eeuu el voto popular no vale para mucho
por no decir para nada lo que cuenta es
el número de representantes que se
obtengan y amigos la relación entre
representantes y votos no es ni mucho
menos perfecta los estados con menos
población están sobrerrepresentados y
son mayoritariamente republicanos esto
es lo que explica que hillary clinton
ganara por 3 millones de votos a donald
trump pero perdiera la presidencia o
también fijaos en esta ilustración
ahora entendéis el buen resultado que el
partido republicano ha tenido en el
senado
[Música]
y este motivo es lo que explica que ante
las elecciones presidenciales algunos
estados sean más importantes que otros
en unas elecciones presidenciales dado
el reparto de pesos lo más importante no
son los bastiones sino los estados en
disputa en los que puede ganar un
partido u otro y a decir verdad aquí el
equipo de trump ha tenido algunos éxitos
muy importantes ha logrado hacerse tanto
con el senador y todo apunta que también
con el gobernador de florida así como
con los gobernadores de ohio iowa
y amigos florida ohio iowa son tres de
los estados más importantes de canadá
presidenciales
en cualquier caso en una economía que
marcha a toda velocidad con la menor
tasa de desempleo en 17 años y una
reducción de impuestos haber obtenido un
resultado tan pobre debería ser
preocupante entre las filas republicanas
y el hecho de que en vez de sacar pecho
hayan tenido que volver a recurrir al
miedo en la campaña e incluso con
anuncios racistas muestra mucho cuál
está siendo el modelo de país que está
dibujando donald trump porque amigos
está claro donald trump no va de la mano
de los entornos más prósperos ni busca
cohesionar el país su estrategia
política pasa por dividir polarizar y
alimentar el odio el presidente trump ha
hecho 6.420 falsas o engañosas
afirmaciones en 649 días pero dicho esto
la gran pregunta que podemos hacernos es
qué iba a pasar ahora que supondrán en
estas elecciones atentos
[Música]
y ahora qué
con una valoración o con otra lo cierto
es que el juego político en los eeuu se
pone aún más al rojo vivo porque amigos
controlar la cámara de representantes-
es más importante de lo que parece pero
qué es exactamente lo que pueden y no
pueden hacer los demócratas pues veréis
gracias al control que ahora pasan a
tener sobre la cámara de representantes
los demócratas van a poder investigar a
trump y al gobierno
[Música]
me explico aprobar una ley y requiere
una mayoría de las dos cámaras del
capitolio en la cámara de representantes
y en el senado así como la firma del
presidente por eso el tema de aprobar
nuevas leyes va a estar muy pero que muy
complicado sin embargo abrir una
investigación sobre el presidente o su
gobierno todo lo requiere del control de
algunas comisiones de la cámara de
representantes y sabéis que los
demócratas tienen ganas ahora van a
poder solicitar las declaraciones de
impuestos que trump se ha negado a
enseñar emitir citaciones para
investigar sus negocios sus posibles
relaciones con operaciones de blanqueo
de capital o muchas de las polémicas que
ha tenido como el despido del ex
director del fbi james com o los pagos a
sus supuestas ex amantes
también van a poder controlar el
presupuesto porque eso es una
responsabilidad de la cámara y aprobar
proyectos de ley que obliguen a los
republicanos a retratarse en el senado e
incluso llegado el caso podrían comenzar
un impeachment aunque luego no tuviera
recorrido en el senado
en fin amigos como veis con estas
elecciones los demócratas han vuelto al
terreno político y contraten la casa
blanca creo que podemos esperar muchos
enfrentamientos pero ahora turno para ti
y vamos hoy con una gran pregunta cómo
valoras los dos primeros años de donald
trump al frente de la casa blanca de 1 a
5 déjanos tu respuesta en esta encuesta
y también claro en los comentarios si te
ha gustado este vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte a visual político un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]